BOOMERS RETIRING EVERY DAY, IT'S
EASIER TO IGNORE THE PROBLEM AND
EASIER TO IGNORE THE PROBLEM ANT
EASIER TO IGNORE THE PROBLEM ANC
EASIER TO IGNORE THE PROBLEM ANL
EASIER TO IGNORE THE PROBLEM ANE
IT.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
OUT WITH THE OLD AND IN WITH THE
NEW.
THAT'S THE IDEA BEHIND ONE
CONGRESSMAN'S PLAN TO DROP HOUSE
AND SENATE MEMBERS SALARIES TO
SERVICE.
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN FRANCIS
ROONEY BELIEVES IT WILL BRING
FRESH IDEAS AND MAKE LAWMAKERS
MORE INDEPENDENT.
JOINING ME NOW SHOULD DISCUSS
IT.
TERM LIMITS WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT.
>> EVERYBODY KNOWS THINGS CAN BE
DIFFICULT, IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO
AMEND THE CONSTITUTION.
THERE ARE 12 BILLS UP TO DO
THAT.
NOW WE CAN FIND OUT IF THOSE
FOLKS WANT TO FISH OR CUT BAIT.
I AM DOING THIS BECAUSE TERM
LIMITS ARE IMPORTANT.
THE CITIZEN LEGISLATOR AND SPOKE
OF THOMAS JEFFERSON IS IMPORTANT
TO OUR COUNTRY.
ROTATING OUT MORE LEGISLATORS
WOULD KEEP THINGS FRESH TO GET
MORE NEW IDEAS, CAPABLE
RESPONSIVE TO THE PEOPLE.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT, YOU WRITE
THAT YOU HAVE SEVEN COSPONSORS,
CONGRESSMAN.
THOMAS JEFFERSON PUBLIC SERVICE
ACT.
IT MEANS EFFECTIVELY PUTTING
TERM LIMITS IN PLACE WITHOUT
AMENDING THE CONSTITUTION,
REDUCING THAT SALARY OF AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF CONGRESS TO $1
A YEAR AFTER THEY SERVE SIX
CONSECUTIVE TERMS IN THE HOUSE
OR TWO CONSECUTIVE TERMS IN THE
SENATE.
HERE IS BILL NELSON FROM FLORIDA
ABOUT WORKING HARD.
>> I AM NOW THE RANKING
DEMOCRAT, AND IF WE GET A
MAJORITY, WE WILL, I WILL BE THE
CHAIRMAN.
IT TAKES TIME TO WORK UP THROUGH
THE SENIORITY SYSTEM.
I WOULD THINK THAT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO
FLORIDA.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
ARGUMENT THAT IT TAKES A WHILE
TO KNOW HOW TO GET AROUND THIS
PLACE AND MAYBE THIS IS NOT,
THIS ARTIFICIAL CAP IS NOT THE
RIGHT CAP.
>> FIRST, I KIND OF RESENT THE
ELITIST PATERNALISM THAT
SENATOR NELSON AND THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTE, SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
SAY THAT THE PEOPLE ELECTED BY
THE PEOPLE CAN'T OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ELECTED THEM.
THAT'S WHAT THE COUNTRY IS BUILT
ON, AN ELECTORAL REPUBLIC.
I THINK WE SHOULD PUT OUR TRUST
AND THE PEOPLE TO GET ELECTED.
SENIORITY AND ATTEMPT
GLOBALIZATION, TECHNOLOGY,
TWITTER, FACEBOOK.
COME ON.
SENIORITY IS AN ANACHRONISM.
>> Bret: WHAT DO YOU SEE THE
PEOPLE WHO LOOK AT YOUR BILL AND
SAY OKAY, SO YOU ARE ENABLING
THE RICH PEOPLE TO RUN BECAUSE
THEY CAN GO WITH A $1 A YEAR AND
IT'S ALL RICH PEOPLE RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS AND SENATE.
>> IT IS A LOGICAL POINT.
I BELIEVE FIRMLY THAT WE ARE THE
CULTURE OF CITIZEN LEGISLATOR TO
TAKE EFFECT, 12 YEARS OVER 99%
OF THE LEGISLATORS ARE DOING THE
12 YEARS AND LEAVING ON SOME OF
THE JOB.
ANY RICH GUY OR LADY WHO WANTS
TO STAY DO THAT IS GOING TO BE
SUCH AN OUTLIER, THEY WOULD BE
ROUNDLY AND VIGOROUSLY OPPOSED.
>> Bret: HERE IS SOMETHING
FROM YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THE
HOUSE AND SENATE ON THE ISSUE.
>> I HAVE WATCHED STATES DO IT.
SOME IT FAILED ON CEMENT WORK.
THE MOST IMPORTANT TERM LIMIT
YOU HAVE IS AT THE BALLOT BOX.
WE HAVE TO SHOW WE CAN WORK AND
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS.
>> I WOULD SAY WE HAVE TERM
LIMITS NOW.
THEY ARE CALLED ELECTIONS.
IT WILL NOT BE ON THE AGENDA.
>> THAT'S WHY 86% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THEM.
I AM A BUSINESS GUY.
I FIGURE OF 86% WANT SOMETHING,
MY JOB IS TO FIGURE HOW TO GET
IT.
>> Bret: THE PROSPECTS OF
MOVING THIS FORWARD, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
SPEAK WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT IF
PEOPLE WANT TO FISH OR CUT BAIT.
THEY ARE 90 COSPONSORS ON THE 12
TERM LIMIT AMENDED BILLS.
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS GUYS, THEY'VE
TALKED ABOUT TERM LIMITS.
SEVERAL OF THEM ARE MY
COSPONSORS.
A LOT OF FRESHMEN HAVE TALKED
ABOUT IT.
THEN THERE IS SOMETHING CALLED A
TERM LIMIT CAUCUS.
LET'S SEE WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
>> Bret: YOU THINK THIS BILL,
IF IT PASSED, COULD GET THROUGH,
LEGALLY?
>> THE OUTCOME OF THE BILL
PEOPLE RESEARCHED IT AND SAID
YEAH.
IT'S THE EFFECTIVE PRACTICE OF
TERM LIMITS BUT NOT HAVING TO